Finally, we need to get the client to ask for
the right image to be downloaded. That is, it needs to
know what device pixel ration the device is using, and potentially
the layout size too, if it's responsive to the layout width.
And then request only the appropriate image. This last part
is the hard part, because the web browser tries to kick
off the image downloads. As early as possible. Which of course
is a good thing for getting content on the screen quickly,
but bad if the client asks for more than
one version, particularly on a mobile device with limited bandwidth.
So how do you think we should approach this problem
of asking for the right image at the right time?